if you're is obsessed with Disney movies
as we are you've probably seen each film
a bazillion times he might have also
realized that Disney movies have their
fair share of animation mistakes
however some can be hard to spot out
which is why if you blink you might miss
them here are 10 Disney movie mistakes
you might have missed Toy Story
time-travel Toy Story is the Disney
Pixar film that changed everything for
the animation world with this new
technology it seems that anything is
possible but time-travel is certainly a
surprise we all know and love Woody and
Buzz Lightyear's journey to return to
Andy's loving arms so Buzz and Woody
were captured by Sid at Pizza palace
when they were pulled out of the alien
Toy Machine the aliens all believed that
they had been chosen clearly they had no
idea of the terrors that awaited Woody
and Buzz at SIDS house we've seen that
Sid can get pretty creative with the
toys in his room he performed surgery on
his sister's doll putting the dinosaur
head on the dolls body in fact there's a
whole underbelly of mutilated toys in
SIDS den of Horrors but with all of
these impressive toys mutilating skills
we must have missed the part where Sid
can time travel if you look at the clock
at the beginning of the scene in SIDS
bedroom the time rates 310 but then a
few minutes later the clock on the wall
leads 10 o'clock we know from the later
films that Sid became a garbage
collector but clearly he should be
working for NASA or maybe it was just an
honest mistake
The Lion King The Lion King is a story
of triumph perseverance and a changing
eye colors in the movie Simba loses his
father then he is chased out of the
pride lands when scar tells him to run
away and never return then Simba finds
Timon and Pumbaa and the Hakuna Matata
their way to Simba's adulthood and
that's when Simba scuppered friend Nala
comes to shake things up for most of the
movie now his eyes are a lovely sky-blue
color but in the scene where this hungry
lioness sees Pumbaa as a delicious
jungle snack and chases him through the
jungle something is different as she is
crouching in the grass before she
pounces on Pumbaa her eyes are suddenly
a vibrant green and after Simba rescues
Pumbaa and recognizes Nala her eyes turn
gray
so do know his eyes change color when
she's hunting what's the deal with
is this a lion thing well according to
lion alert org a lions eyes will change
color but not the way knowledge did in
the movie a lions eyes are blue grain
color when they are born
however they change to an amber color at
two to three months old so apparently
this is just a Disney animation mistake
monsters ink Monsters Inc is a Disney
Pixar film that is full of hilarious
moments but one moment really stand out
in the monster world they believe that
if a human child touches a monster it
means the end of that monsters life this
sets up a hilarious role reversal as it
makes these giant monsters scared of
tiny human children if a monster comes
into contact with any human object
certain precautions are taken to avoid
contamination so when George emerges
from a child to closet door with a
little tiny sock stuck to his back his
coworker yells out that they have a
23-19 this causes a full panic and
shutdown at the factory while the CDA or
child detection agency jumps into action
they carefully remove the baby sock with
these huge tongs and blow it up in a
bomb bubble then they tackle george
shave off his fur give him a spontaneous
shower and rip off a strip of tender
monster skin where the sock was poor
George
with all that action it's easy to
overlook the animation mistake first the
sock is turned one way and then in the
next shot it is turned around the
opposite way Beauty and the Beast it's a
tale as old as time but that doesn't
make this classic Disney movie immune to
mistakes gently gently in Beauty and the
Beast a young princess cursed when he
refuses to give an old woman shelter
from the cold and stormy weather after
he turns her away she turns into a
beautiful sorceress and puts a curse on
the young prince she turns him into the
Beast until he can find someone to love
him for who he is on the inside he must
find true love to break this curse
before his 21st birthday or he will be
doomed to remain a beast for the rest of
his days as you can imagine the Prince
didn't take this well at all in fact he
threw a huge beastly fit and destroyed
many things in this castle one of the
things he destroys is an old painting of
himself in human form he slashes through
it with his mask
Claus and this is where the mistake
happens initially the slash marks and
the pain team go from left to right at
the downward angle
but when bow wanders and through that
forbidden room later in the movie the
slash marks go the opposite direction of
course this mistake doesn't take away
from the film it's still awesome frozen
and speaking of Awesome Disney movies
frozen gave fans everywhere an avalanche
of emotions when it first came out
this film proves that the power of true
love can exist between sisters - and not
just a prince and princess in fact this
movie poked fun at Disney's tendency of
marrying new couples within a very short
timeframe yes and who can forget the
power ballad when Elsa sings at the top
of her snowy mountain this song is
responsible for every toddler living
room performance session in the world
we've seen this movie a dozen times and
still get all choked up when Elsa
changes into her crystal embellished
dress and lets down her long braid we
love this movie so much so we hate to
point out this super noticeable
animation mistake but we're gonna do it
anyway somebody gotta tell him during
the iconic scene when Elsa becomes the
snow queen of her isolated Kingdom she
lets her braid down but when she pulls
the braid forward it passes right
through her shoulder but you know what
we loved this movie so much we're
totally willing to let it go see what we
did there all right moving on Aladdin
we've already pointed out a weird human
anatomy mistake made by the animators of
Disney's Aladdin in our previous video
and we've recently pointed out an
animation mistake involving a certain
grumpy suitor who lost his underpants to
Jasmin's tiger raja we promise we're not
picking on this movie however we did
notice another notable mistake toward
the end of the film it involves Princess
Jasmine and a certain evil Sultan
there's a part where Jafar captures the
lamp and demands that Genie makes the
princess fall in love with him we all
know from the beginning of the film that
genie can't make anyone fall in love I
can't make anybody fall in love with
anybody else but Jafar wasn't privy to
that conversation
so Jasmine decides to distract Jafar by
pretending she's in love with him so
that Aladdin can steal the lamp back
during the scene we notice a little
oopsie moments regarding Jasmine's
wardrobe particularly with a gold
armband she's wearing at
first the gold bracelet is on her right
arm but then after she kisses Jafar and
he realizes she was trying to trick him
he shoves her down then the gold
bracelet is on her left arm
oopsy lilo and Stitch Disney's lilo and
stitch reminds us all about the meaning
of family and that no one gets left
behind lilo tries to fit in with her
peers but she quickly sticks out like a
sore thumb which isn't exactly a bad
thing in the beginning Lila was running
late for a hula dance rehearsal she
storms in soaking wet and dripping all
over the floor the wet spots on the
floor caused the other dancers to slip
and fall when lilo explains why she was
late it's still rather confusing to the
adults but she ran out of peanut butter
so she had to go get some more her
sister suggested that she just feed a
tuna sandwich to Pudge which was very
distressing to lilo and she insists that
Pudge controls the weather the grown-ups
look at each other completely
dumbfounded and that's when we noticed a
continuity error at the beginning of the
scene we see drummers drumming on
identical drums but after lilo tells her
Pudge the fish story one of the drums
are different Mulan at the beginning of
Mulan Mulan must impress a matchmaker in
order to be matched with a husband who
will bring honor to her family please
Mulan's meeting with the matchmaker
doesn't go very well
her grandmother gives me Lana cricket
for good luck but the cricket gets her
into a whole lot of trouble Mulan has
written notes on her wrists so she can
pass her test with flying colors the
matchmaker grabbed Mulan's wrist robbing
the ink from Mulan's
arm onto her fingers the woman then rubs
her fingers on her face making it look
like she's rocking a goatee Mulan pours
some tea at the matchmakers request and
just as the matchmaker is about to drink
Mulan's he's heard cricket relaxing in
the tea like it's a hot tub she tries to
wrestle the tea cup away from the
matchmaker in the process the cricket
falls down the matchmakers blouse
causing her to fall onto a pile of hot
coals her rear end catches on fire the
Mulan does the only logical thing she
splashes her in the face with a pot of
hot tea we don't want to nitpick but we
think she splashed the wrong area and to
be honest we're still not sure how the
tush fire was
- mushed wreckit-ralph vanellope von
schweetz demonstrates what happens to
your teeth when you eat too much sugar
in wreck-it Ralph there's the scene
where broth is trying to teach vanellope
how to drive her new Albia - genki cart
which she calls the lickety-split she is
cruising hard and fast around her
underground racetrack when she crashes
the cart knocking out a tooth in the
process this is probably because her
teeth are weak and full of cavities from
all that sugar you think that her tooth
is probably gone for the rest of the
movie right wrong somehow her tooth
magically reappears a few seconds later
either the sugar rush game has the
fastest dental care in the universe or
they made an animation mistake we think
they have done it on purpose so that
Penelope wouldn't have a gap in her
teeth for the rest of the film although
that would have been pretty cool and
when you think about it it totally fits
her character Penelope's already got a
bunch of candy is stuck in her hair it
would have been fun to hear her sassy
comments come out with a slight Lisp due
to her missing tooth now we got him Toy
Story 2 we all want to believe our
favorite cartoon characters are real but
when the movies accidentally prove the
contrary it's hard to know what to think
take this Toy Story 2 scene for example
you know the one where the characters
are watching television when they turn
it off there are no reflection of the
characters on the screen so are the toys
like vampires we mean why else wouldn't
they have a reflection or is this an
example of a time when the animators got
a little lazy and hoped that the loyal
fans would overlook their mishap well
we're here to tell you that the fans
noticed Toy Story 2 showed another
shining example of toys and Friends
sticking together no matter what even
when they appear to be totally invisible
while we are pretty sure this is an
animation oversight it's fun to imagine
alternatives for why they can't see
their own reflections on the screen
perhaps it's a commentary on the way the
regular tactile toys are becoming
obsolete in the modern world or maybe it
was just an honest mistake for the time
being the toys missing reflection
remains a mystery got any theories of
your own we'd love to hear all about
them are there any Disney movie mistakes
we missed if so tell us in the comments
and that's the end of our video as usual
give this video a big thumbs up don't
forget to subscribe to the things thanks
for watching we'll see you
soon
[Music]